another embarrassing moment for Joe
Biden the Supreme Court has struck down
the president's half a trillion dollar
student loan bailout program and the
ruling the commander-in-chief had
overstepped his executive Authority but
the big guy says this fight isn't over
you know these Republican officials just
couldn't bear the thought of providing
relief for working class middle class
Americans just stop fighting for you
we'll use every tool at our disposal to
get you the student debt relief you need
and reach your dreams why did you give
millions of borrowers false hope I
didn't get bars false hope but the
Republicans snatched away the hope that
it was they were given and it's real
real hope did you overstep your
Authority I think the court
misinterpreted the Constitution
here it goes but maybe Biden should save
some of that anger for Nancy Pelosi the
Supreme Court actually using the former
speaker's own words in the ruling
people think that the president of the
United States has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone he can delay
but he does not have that power that
would that's to be an act of Congress
yeah as you can imagine the media and
Democrats well they're not very happy
this court is a political Court this
court is a trumpian court these
decisions are trumpist decisions the
Supreme Court proceeded to ignore the
will of Congress in order to deprive
more than 40 million households of
student debt forgiveness these decisions
over the last 24 hours are essentially
making it harder for a range of
communities to go to college and seek a
higher education allowing the the courts
to legitimize and license discrimination
in this kind of way really makes our
country not the country that we want it
to be and I hope that they will find
other ways to carry through this this
promise
all right judge we need to talk about
the legalities here
president Bon tried to use the heroes
act and Supreme Court said hey Congress
has the way in here you can't spend this
much money the ACT doesn't give you the
authority to spend this much money
unless you go to Congress so when they
say uh overrode the will of Congress
well the Congress hasn't said it hasn't
expressed its will but now he's going to
go to The Higher Education Act and in my
very
novice understanding it looks like it
paves the way a lot more smoothly well
look that what happened with the Supreme
Court as they said the federal law does
not allow the Secretary of Education in
any way to cancel 430 billion dollars
worth of student loan debts Biden knew
it in 2020 he knew it yeah Nancy Pelosi
as you just uh showed in that sound knew
it and said it in 2021 and the truth is
that they used it as a ploy for the 2022
midterms Biden wanted to bring along
young people and try to make sure that
the midterms were not going to be the
bloodbath that he believed and all the
Democrats believed was going to be the
case the operative statute was a Heroes
act which allows the Secretary of
Education and it was it was enacted in
2001 to modify or wave to some extent
um the the ability of a student to repay
a loan if that student is in the
military goes abroad yeah and the
Supreme Court came out and said well the
heroes act allows you to kind of wait to
waive it or modify it doesn't allow you
to just cancel it outright you can't do
that so it's it's so the legalities are
very clear everybody knew that he didn't
have the right to do it let's not make
believe he did have the right to do it
and so he comes out today and he says
you know it's those Republicans and it's
it's it's it's about the Republicans are
destroying the middle class the truth is
that it's Joe Biden that's doing that
he's put trillions into the economy
these put us in a position where uh you
know the ordinary person is not able to
survive the inflation cost of gas the
cost of food and everything else and
he's making like you know these student
loans should you know they're the most
important things going on in the country
no they need to know if they signed a
contract they have to agree to repay the
contract especially in light of the fact
that you're making us pay for their loan
that you have improved to me that they
can't pay and in truth that you know
kids decided not to go to college kids
decided to repay the loan and now the
kids who didn't who already are home
collecting checks from whatever else is
going on are going to say gee I'm going
to take advantage of this and the the
the worst thing is when the president
came out at 3 30 or 4 o'clock today and
he said well look at what happened at
the uh what was it after the covet after
the pandemic you know all these people
were allowed to get money from from
covid and from the uh from the PPP the
truth is the government shut businesses
down the government didn't allow
businesses to operate they were entitled
to that the government forced them to
shut down these kids are not entitled to
it end of the story you know Greg the
real irony here is Republicans put four
bills out one of them was really great
though and I think somebody kind of
jumped the shark on this one so one of
the bills said Hey listen before you can
take this loan out we're going to make
sure you're getting a degree that you
can make enough money to pay it back
they're kind of looking at defunding
indoctrination yeah that's true that's
too logical I want to put
I felt bad watching our president get so
upset over this because I don't think he
quite understands the whole you know the
meaning of what's going on so I want to
put the loan Fiasco in a way he
understands let's say you're selling
Hunter's paintings right for like 200
Grand each to be paid off for some kind
of installment plan you're out you
celebrate it's going to happen
everything's and then suddenly a third
party intervenes and says you know what
those monthly fees have been canceled
and they're being transferred onto you
the Biden family or let's say hunters in
China and he's making it rain he got the
big guy 20 million and then all of a
sudden zelinski says no that money's for
me we need it more than you Joe that
would upset him that's why this didn't
work because it was just theft it wasn't
anything else other than theft I love
how the media covering this solemnly
says and they say this this was verbatim
so this means that students who have
huge loans they're going to have to pay
them back it's like yes you bozo that's
how it's always worked or alone in a
contract is utterly meaningless right
you can never give out another loan to
anybody if you think it's going to be
forgiven because the people will rebel I
would be for this if they forced the the
colleges yeah to do it but they're not
no they're not that and so if they force
it on the colleges the colleges would
not go for this debt relief so that's
the thing you know I I I it is all
Academia they triple they tripled they
tripled their fees because they knew
everybody was going to get a loan yeah
it caused a relationship with banks and
then it's kind of like a three-step
Ponte scheme right academic Academia
gets the money from the banks the banks
get the money from the students and the
students they get their money from their
parents yeah and they're the ones that
rude and the jobs
I mean it's not a conservative Supreme
Court it's not a liberal one you know
it's a Libertarian it's as libertarian
as it gets it's championing the rights
of the individual over the demands of
the group it's protecting your right to
expression from people compelling you to
say things you don't want to say Don't
force me don't force customers to
express
the cut don't don't for don't cause a
company to express the beliefs of a
customer that's number one we don't want
to pay other people's loans and we don't
want to be forced to hire people based
on race you're not compelling people to
do these things that's what that's what
the Constitution the three decisions are
all United by a Libertarian power and
the liberal and by the way liberals
should relax
you really need this court it's the only
thing stopping you from yourself you got
government you got culture you got media
you got education right you don't need
your radical clause in the Supreme Court
that's the ref you got the ball you got
the teams you got the you got the crowd
and the field let the common sense
people have the refs Killian on the
politics of it you know you had you
heard that last question did you
purposefully mislead people this is a
pretty good voting block here that Biden
wants to lean on now they've gone out
and borrowed money on credit cards
thinking they were getting this in a
Biden economy who's going to get the
blame will they blame Republicans or
will they blame Biden they're going to
blame him because he promised it to them
and he knew this was a long shot and
that it would take a long time because
it would go all the way to the Supreme
Court so if it was that urgent and that
exigent he could have gone to Congress
that's really all this opinion says is
that in our constitution the separation
of powers means the executive branch
cannot play the role of Congress you
can't exceed your Authority in this case
it wasn't even Biden it was the
Secretary of Education already a weak
position having a very thin statutory
Authority and trying to expand that into
half a trillion dollars of debt loan
forgiveness you know Joey public opinion
wise this was never as popular as they
thought it'd be from the beginning
because people read it for what it was
from the start it was never as popular
in 2022 the polls have never truly
supported it and fair questions why
because people know how unfair it is to
ask a pipefitter in Peoria or a
hairdresser in Hialeah to pay for the
student loans of a lawyer in Washington
DC or a doctor in New York City it's
just not fair to people and so if you
make a different choice in life and
let's just pretend you've paid off your
student loans now you're going to pay
them off for other people because you're
a taxpayer is on the hook here the other
thing is Biden just always gets angry at
female reporters I love seeing it it's
an angry old cause he's like the crazy
uncle in the Attic he's telling the
whole country get off my lawn and that's
not a good look for 2024 but here's why
it's going to hurt him because he seems
to be on the wrong side of Common Sense
and all these Supreme Court decisions
and here's the real reason why it's
going to hurt him the Democrats are
screaming about no race and college
admissions about not being compelled to
conform to somebody else's belief if you
want to keep your business surviving and
thriving and now not be compelled to pay
off student loans for other people yeah
but the Democrats you can't find one in
Washington D.C who's for school choice
and charter schools and educational
Freedom opportunity scholarships they
are keeping kids
of all backgrounds including if not
especially in our inner cities trapped
in these failing schools won't let the
money we're all going to keep paying for
those kids to follow the kid and give
him or her a quality affordable
education that they that's worthy of
their humanity and dignity so I don't
want to hear one more lecture for one
more liberal or one more person named
Biden including the dogs about
educational freedom and making a better
life for yourself until they take a
second look at school choice Harold
speaking of a Democrat you can't find in
D.C if you were a member of Congress in
the Democrat Party right now would you
be blaming the Supreme Court or saying
hey guys we need to get a piece of
legislation together well I'm a Democrat
Richie Torres who's the congressman uh
one of the new congressmen here from New
York is a huge supporter of of
everything you just talked about Kelly
and I think they're they're more
Democrats along that line and I would
agree with you two things I thought that
and I'm sitting on the show I thought
that uh what the president tried to do
here they should have tailored this I
think they should have uh tailored it to
only provide loan relief for those uh
who have degrees that really are meeting
a need in the economy Engineers
including electricians and plumbers
nurses teachers family doctors needed
the air traffic controls well that's
that's what our economy needs yeah we're
not producing enough of that enough of
them so if you're going to if you're
going to provide people with that kind
of relief we should do that the PPP
example that the that the judge gave and
and kellyanne just mentioned remember we
we gave every business person an
opportunity to pay his or her uh
employees for several months because we
did shut down business but these kids
can go back to work either so it would
have probably been better to pay the
loans for a certain period of time like
we did with the PPP I give the president
credit for a big idea but they've got to
go back to the drawing board and figure
this out now we've talked about the
supreme court and the judge you
mentioned yesterday I think this is this
decision here along with the Striking
down of Road the Striking down of
affirmative action uh the the allowance
of basically allowing gays in the
country to be treated differently this
will be on the ballot no no just my
characterization of it when I'm agreeing
with you yesterday you said these things
will be on the ballot like Roe wasn't
22. this will be on the ballot again and
it's unfortunate because the Supreme
Court shouldn't be on the ballot uh the
Supreme Court is is is that branch of
government that we would hope would be
the Arbiter and could be the referee but
they stand today at a 27 Cent approach
27 approval rating I think you look at
these decisions you look at the fact
they don't have a code of ethics and I
think this issue also is going to be
litigated politically litigated come
next year as well I hope it isn't I hope
we don't litigate the court I hope the
court is standing is able re-rise or
rise again but we're at a bad point in
the low point in how the legitimacy of
the court is perceived that you have the
Chief Justice John Roberts pretty much
scolding publicly other justices from
sticking in their descents sniping and
other justices they're saying the sin is
a long-standing we have a long-standing
history I'm sorry
to say this I don't know how he blamed
the Supreme Court for the president
trying to use something for military
service members to give a gender studies
uh a discount so I don't know hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else